meanwhile the Tokyo Summer Olympics are
hanging in the balance now a veteran
member of the International Olympic
Committee dick pound told USA Today that
postponement has already been decided
ramie Inocencio reports from tokyo good
morning it's important to note the
International Olympic Committee has not
decided to postpone the games at least
not yet but CBS News did reach out to
the IOC for a reaction and they said
that every board member has a right to
interpret the Board's decision but dick
pound has a lot of influence and it's
very likely the games will be postponed
to 2021 just five days after the Olympic
flame landed in Japan its future and
that of the entire 2020 Summer Games is
in doubt Team USA voiced its support for
a postponement saying in a statement
even if the current significant health
concerns could be alleviated by late
summer the enormous disruptions to the
training environment doping controls and
qualification process can't be overcome
it's definitely way beyond sports it's
all about health and safety of not only
yourselves but the ones around you Team
USA sprinter manio Mitchell took home a
silver medal in 2012 he says postponing
the games would be bittersweet but
fellow athletes getting sick has him
concerned here I am professional athlete
I could possibly get this and not even
know especially with my immune system
being as strongly as it is so you know
I'm taking all the proper proper
precautions that you know the CDC is
putting out first time Olympian Kate
Courtney is a mountain biker who
qualified for the Tokyo Games
she said it'd be a huge disappointment
not to compete I've been riding
virtually with Olympians from different
countries I can train from my home gym
and share videos on Instagram and see
what other people are doing and the IOC
says they'll have a final decision in
the next four weeks but fewer people
here in Japan and around the world
really expect that any kind of Olympic
fireworks will end up over the national
stadium this summer for CBS this morning
Rainey Inocencio Tokyo